all right
suresh ramaswamy hello welcome
delighted to be here atlas it's such a
treat
i'm looking forward to this conversation
yes
me too what a
critical voice you are in
igniting our enlightenment as a planet
i'm so pumped for those that don't know
suresh's background he's a
transformational teacher and visionary
entrepreneur passionate about igniting
and catalyzing the transformation of
humanity
and he authored a book called just
be transform your life and live as
infinity
and he provides an exceptional way for
us
to recognize that the so-called piercing
the veilus veiler the gateless gate
has its so-called
pops or steps and that
to have a harmonic
process in integrating
and awakening and sharing
butterfly affecting out that radiant
love light
is so paramount
absolutely well put well put
uh yes so it's a it's a beautiful
process of
flowering that we're going through both
individually and collectively
and so i think it's it's really very
pertinent
uh to what's going on our our
conversation today
i would invite the viewers
to not only
listen to this as a
exchange of ideas and concepts but
really more importantly as an
invitation to swim in
infinity because that's really what's
going on here
we're swimming in infinity and saying
hey come on jump in
jump in that's really the point uh and
not
endless in elephants we want to jump in
we want to splash in the light
we want to delight in the sheer joy of
our own existence
and that's really what beingness is all
about and that's that's
really what i would like to invite at
the outset
i love it
[Laughter]
oh yes a
appearance a cameo
of the divine of eternity
here we are yes
yes yeah
jump in stop the suffering
increase the joy in the peace maximize
the potential
of the civilization yes
and really you know all all the
suffering all the suffering
from all the times in the past all that
the point has been just this to jump
into this ocean right now it's that's
what it's all come down to
for every person listening this is this
is the moment
for you uh that this is the point
to jump in and all that suffering is
meant to really
motivate you focus you and
make you enthusiastic about jumping into
this
portion of joy
yeah the suffering is the drill sergeant
of awakening yeah and
the reason why the
in the analysis that i've understood
there's a avoiding as the
infinite and the void as the shunya the
emptiness the nothingness the very black
wholeness
and that the process of sort of
fractaling
away from the void is
in itself sort of the most like
intoxicative individuated
aspect and so to quote
swim in infinity or to
die before you die as many of the
mystics have said also
just that process in itself
is both great for the eradication of
suffering because you recognize it's all
the same beautiful
one intelligence at play with itself
and yet then it makes it so that you can
properly fractal outward as your
firework
and not commit malevolence or suffering
so
the in the actual in a sense forcing
function the very creative forcing
function itself
in a sense has both the
callback process of yoga or union with
the absolute
yet also it has the process of no
the whole point was for me to get away
from the void
yeah very interesting that's an
excellent way to put it
because there's the process of you know
evolution
and involution and so there's
the moving away because we wanted the
excitement of individuation we wanted
that we were like
what could be more exciting than feeling
like we're not part of the infinite even
though you can never ever
be apart from it but what if we could
just
get that feeling wouldn't that be
exciting so we
we experimented with individuation and
it was more than we bargained for
perhaps
it was exciting and a whole lot more
and right then there comes a point where
it's like wait i i want to be
back in touch with my infinite source
with my infinite essence
turns out that turning that pure
wanting to turn back is really what's
needed
you don't now have to go through some
big qualification process that
well let's check your password let's
check you you
are by definition an emanation
of that infinite and so you
you're turning back is easier than you
think you you just try to shake off a
lot of stuff
and you got to get this very
clear-minded single-pointed
pure intention that
i want to be recognizing realizing
this union
with infinity so that's
really what it's all about and it's
in many ways it's so simple it's really
very simple
it's not terribly complicated um
but of course you you want to feel your
way back so there's an intuitive
aspect to it and i think you were
talking about it atlas in in
different ways in you can look at this
as the functions that
drive you away and then there are
functions which draw you back
and once you learn to cooperate with
these forces
you find that you're riding the wave
back it's not like you're fighting
fighting fighting
you have to align yourself with these
forces
these intelligences that will
pull you back that'll pull you back just
like the gravitational
force of a larger planetary body
it overcomes any uh smaller thing
floating around
it dominates and so we we need to
just like when satellites are sent
across the solar system
they really look at you know big planets
right the jupiters and the saturn's
so that you can use their gravitational
pull
instead of just having to burn fuel
and so once you know the right orbit
you can use the gravitational pull of
jupiter and that's really what's going
to take you it's not your own little
self-propelled little engine that's
gonna take you there
so we could call that grace we could
call that so many things
um but it's really this pure alignment
with this bigger
thing we can call it whatever the
wholeness the intelligence the infinity
yeah that's really powerful so the
component that
is continuously referred to
across many of the guests
that come on the program is that
when you don't know your true nature
as this cameo of eternity slash infinity
what happens is when you don't know
yourself as the very
source of awareness and realities
themselves when you don't know yourself
as that when you haven't went through
this
so-called neti neti not this not that
process of negating
yourself as simply a person
and even negating yourself as awareness
and then recognizing that you're
actually the source of awareness and
realities themselves
and that there is this massive vortexing
of one intelligence at play with itself
only after that point of going inward
which is usually catalyzed by
suffering when lakshmi in
maya is drawing you out as a person
towards experiences and
relationships and substances everything
outward
trying to seek peace and happiness and
objects and like in the archetypal story
the parable of prodigal son you get hit
in the head with the sledgehammer
and then you're like okay okay i will
turn inward and analyze
awareness maybe there is such a non the
existence consciousness
and and so that happens and
only from knowing yourself as the source
of the realities and the awareness
themselves
will you then be able to properly
firework
as the unique individuated spark of the
infinite
where you radiate like the
sun the peace and the happiness of the
natural state of existence
and then you serve for the planetary
architectures in pure service to other
people
rather than the very contracted person
identity that is
unable to find peace and happiness
anywhere it looks because it doesn't
know
its true nature and so that's the
process of in a sense
yoga union mysticism going all the way
in communing uniting with the natural
source that you are and then going
outward
in this sachin ananda fireworking
beautiful beautiful yeah i talk about it
as a
as three phases if you will of this
grand
process the first piece is
transcending because enmeshed
in this reality we can we can struggle
we can be like what else is going on all
i can see is
pain suffering torment trepidation
turbulence i don't like this that's all
i know i just don't like it
so it requires this transcendence so we
can glimpse
something beyond and so this
transcendence
you could you could get it through
various uh ways of
of uh disciplining yourself disciplining
your mind your senses and so on so
netique would be for example one
way of sort of simplifying
what you see around you and going back
to the pristine
truth of your being so this
transcendence is
more often than not a series of glimpses
because you
you see something and then you're back
here and then okay it's monday
morning you know get back to my work and
i have to drive through traffic and this
and that
and when's the next retreat you know
that's what i'm looking forward to
so this transcendence is up and down up
and down up and down
but every time we go up we are seeing a
little bit more
and hopefully stabilizing a little bit
more
and so in every step there's traps
but for now i'll just keep it simple
it's seeing
the forest instead of the trees this is
what transcendence
you see see the big picture and the big
picture
when it's seen then you are never the
same again
because even if it's a glimpse you know
it's true it's not just a secondhand
knowledge
you know it's true some people
if they had a quantum shift they think
this
is it because now i am really seeing
this thing
and i know this is way different than
what i used to be last week
clearly i'm enlightened
end of story so we have this uh
we want to get there fast and we want to
quickly put our flag
that got it enlightened suresh
made it that's it yes all as well
now i can open some new instagram
accounts and so forth
but uh we we may be a little rushed in
there because
there are aspects of our being which are
not
quite there yet so part of us yes
we have an authentic glimpse of the
ultimate truth
but there may be some aspects which are
not quite there they're still
lurking in in the basement in the closet
and we need to bring the whole gang
you know to the this big view so this
process
is this integration because integration
is saying
there is still some friction i can see
within me uh part of me is way up there
part of me is not quite there so there's
this friction that you feel and there's
no denying that
so even if you claim anything this
friction will tell you
wait a minute there's something that
still needs work that needs attention
and that's good news because you might
as well do it
uh this integration work you if you
really want to stabilize in the
higher states you've got to do this work
now integration is not very glamorous
because uh
it can it can feel like it's not so much
fun not too many people are
writing letters back home about their
integration process because it's just
like
no fun whereas transcendence you want to
write
letters back home like let me tell you
about this amazing experience i had with
light
that's your transcendent experience that
you want to talk about
integration is like i can't believe i'm
still
dealing with this thing that happened to
me 2500 years back
i'm still dealing with it so but it's
important so integration is that process
then that naturally leads to what i call
embodiment
which is this now
i can live as this infinite being
through this finite container radiating
light
sharing light uplifting the collective
presenting myself as a pure instrument
as a pure channel
for the infinite so that's the
embodiment process and that too is very
significant
now all these all right i look at these
the very
broad you know broad brush transcendence
integration embodiment
and we can go into this in a lot more
detail but i think
when we really get into trouble is we
just
pay attention to transcendence and many
traditions have emphasized transcendence
and not so much integration and
embodiment
and so you you end up over emphasizing
transcendence
and you have a hard time
functioning in this reality you can end
up saying
oh this physical reality you know it's
not real anyway
so why should i bother right
i'm gonna sit in my sachitananda i'm
gonna sit in my bliss
and i'm gonna find a really nice cave
someplace
and sit there that's it and people will
come to me
and i will bless them
so this this is this is you're missing a
big thing there
which is being out in the world that's
where you really
get to see if the realization
is durable reliable
is it does it stick is it stable
this takes time and it takes
wisdom to say okay let me do what needs
to be done
this is work that's very important too
and so this is a little bit simplified
approach actually there's a lot more
going on than just
it's not like you only do transcendence
then you only do integration
it's not like that in fact there's a lot
going on in parallel
but if this makes it a little easier to
understand
from a macro perspective yes we can
we can step in and look at the more
micro perspective that there's
even if you have like an awesome
meditation
over the weekend you can integrate that
right away right you don't have to wait
for all the integra
all the transcendence to pile up then
start the integration work you can be
doing integration
every little shift which is the smart
thing to do
that way wherever you are you are
in a stable balanced
relatively optimal place so it's not
wobbly
right that's you don't want to be wobbly
along the path
because you know you see that where
people have tasted something amazing
but they're pretty wobbly why because
there's a lot of stuff that's still
needs to be addressed
wow so relatable and such a good
road map for awakening such a good
aspect to this unified theory of
spirituality
that is really being birthed right now
that's very exciting
because we have so
many thousands of years
of mystics and yogis and
different processes and methods
styles of uniting with the true nature
through this veilus veil through this
gateless gate
and to have
a a navigable roadmap
for awakening that
especially the
most dense civilizational
economic machinery and governments
politicians
propaganda all of that can also
be able to see and can
also be able to leverage and say hey
if one of our employees is beginning a
process of
getting these quote glimpses of
recognizing their nature as being a
spark of the
infinite and them being significantly
beyond
just being this physical person in this
finite
reality but they're beginning to get
this taste of being the source of
awareness and realities themselves that
then there can be a process of maybe
their friends their family their
co-workers
online communities the basic process for
them to
integrate said transcendence into
the more stabilization integration is
all about
stabilization of these stages
of awakening and then like you said
these stages
happen simultaneously with you slowly
begin
embodying more and more of your
transcendent stages to where you can
tell that you're no longer radiating out
suffering and malevolence and anger and
jealousy
envy hatred ill will but you begin
radiating out compassion and love and
peace and bliss and joy and wanting to
maximize human potential and create
those architectures to be in service to
other people you begin
being like the very sun what is meant by
enlightenment and so it's very critical
you also mentioned the middle path or
the middle way
it's the most important aspect to this
as well along with
not falling into these crevices
like we mentioned where you
go and any expression of the infinite is
its own unique
expression so if you'd like to go off to
the cave
go for it if you'd like to
experience what it's like to have an
awakening
having a transcendent experience and
then getting in a sense
pulled back by those said
civilizational architectures that are a
little bit more archaic like the
governments and economic machineries and
maybe you get sent into
a diagnostic of
by psychiatric dsm-5
being put into a mental facility
these types of things still happening in
the west
and the versus the east in a sense being
like congratulations on your non-dual
experience
and and so it whatever firework of the
infinite is its own unique flavor and
taste and it's a process of the one
intelligence learning about itself
yet at the same time we're road mapping
out these crevices for you to know so
that you don't slip
into a 50-foot crevice that was covered
by snow
and then suffocate because there was
nobody there to
help steward you along the way that's
been on the trajectory before
and so the middle path is all about
tantra it's all about
weaving it's all about ramana maharshi
said sahaja samadhi
you weave your profound realizations
into the social fabric itself that's the
ultimate
test is can you be awake as a normie
and can you do it in a way that's
harmonic
in the ascension of consciousness of its
awakening to its true infinite nature
perfect yeah that's beautiful and it's
also a recognition of the fact
that nobody wakes up nobody gets
enlightened
in isolation we're part of the
collective
so what happens is once you have a
deeper
realization now that has to be fed into
the collective
you can't just have this isolated
enlightenment thing and disappear you
are still part of the collective at many
levels
and embodiment is a recognition of our
connection
so in fact it it ends up being
you can choose how you want to embody
there's a wide range of ways to embody
it's going to look
different for everybody it's not about
being a teacher by any means
it can look like anything but each
person has to find that way
where they are feeding into that
collective and
really living as that unity so
you know we say okay i'm in unity
consciousness well are you
if you're not living that then it's just
a nice little thing you have in your
head that
i'm part of everything if you're living
unity consciousness
what i call living as infinity then
you're living and
breathing that connection
so it becomes a matter of
it's it becomes a natural way of
functioning
really um and so it's it's an
evolutionary process now again a lot of
these things
need to take their own time but i i
think just like you said atlas there's
just knowing there's a map and what i
wanted to do
with with what i share in my book is
that
i want to provide something that is uh
independent of any existing system or
tradition
or religion because all of them even
though there are some
absolutely awesome traditions out there
they are still enmeshed in certain
constructs
and sometimes it's hard to tell apart
which is the
real thing and then the extra thing
that's been added on
and so we it's so confusing so i want to
pull it out of all that in in in plain
english
say these are the things so that
somebody who
who's not bought into some xyz tradition
can still relate to it can still use it
so there's a the process map which is
what we just talked about there's also a
map that i
share in my book about the reality that
we find ourselves in
how do you make sense of this reality uh
you know
it's easy to say oh this whole thing is
is it's totally an illusion let's
not talk about it but there is
actually a structure
to that and so i call it infinity and
the fields of
light to really help us
navigate these dimensions because
there's a very finite
dimension which we are very familiar
with through our five senses
but then there's subtler and subtler and
subtler and subtler dimensions
and these subtle dimensions are
significant
we don't want to get carried away with
them but they are significant
because as we navigate and find our way
back
to who we truly are we're going to bump
into these subtler
aspects of ourselves and
this reality so if we have a map of that
it helps a lot because number one you
can say okay
looks like i'm moving in the right
direction number two
very important you don't get stuck
someplace
thinking this is it i've arrived this is
heaven
end of story well it turns out it's just
a nice
subtle astral plane that you ended up in
so you don't want to
get get carried away with that and
settle down there
you once you have a map you're like oh
i'm still
in denver and i'm driving to california
i've still got a
long i've still got to cross the rockies
and go through utah arizona i've still
got ways to go
so at least it gives you that sense of
yes i've made progress
but i gotta keep going so that's the
whole map of reality
which takes you from this more matter
physical reality to energy
to light and then light
to pure consciousness go through those
one more time for us
so physical reality or matter based
reality
behind that is energy
so we're talking subtle energy here but
to simplify
matter energy and then beyond that is
light
and this light is very significant
this is not our ordinary light i'm not
talking about the electromagnetic
light that we typically see
coming out of a light bulb light i'm
talking about is transcendental light
and transcendental light is well beyond
the electromagnetic
spectrum it is
it's we could think of it as uh the
highest
purest vibration that exists within
creation
that's this pure light i sometimes call
it
the light of infinity because it's the
most
fundamental emanation that
that came out of source that came out of
infinity
so imagine there's only pure
consciousness
right there's only pure consciousness as
the
idea of a creation started coming about
creative intelligence for creating
creation that was the first thing that
came out of pure consciousness
from that creative intelligence came the
very
first highest vibrations of creation
the most fundamental vibrations and
those are that's the light
i'm talking about the light of infinity
one of the cool things about light is we
can engage with light
and we can call upon light because our
own nature
includes light this is not something out
there
this is very much part of us as we
look at ourselves if i can just check in
so it could be visualized as
from source it going light energy matter
or from the physical person
consciousness going
from matter to energy to light is that
right yes
okay exactly okay exactly perfect
so um yes
so once we understand this very
broad sense of what creation
is about then we also see that we
too are actually all of these things
are cells so there's a matter aspect to
us which is the
very physical body there's a subtle
energy aspect to us which are energetic
body
and there's a light aspect to us you
could call it the light body
just to keep it easy so this is very
much part of us
too now this light now
which is an aspect of us a higher aspect
of us
we can engage with that work with that
we can invoke that
because there is enormous power
in the higher aspects of our own being
and we might as well
leverage this enormous power within us
to take us back to source so
we can even the relative realities
we can function intelligently
rather than simply thinking okay there's
this physical reality okay the real
thing is the source everything else is
maya everything else is
illusion okay let's not worry about it
you you you end up functioning in a way
that
pulls you out in a very powerful way
because
light is just amazingly
powerful and amazingly
benevolent and it connects us to the
source
so why not use that as a way to get
back to our essence
so that's another piece of the puzzle in
terms of you know how do we get back
there in an expeditious
manner because we want to get back there
but i don't want to struggle inch by
inch
how do i get back there in a graceful
elegant beautiful way and
apps it is absolutely possible and i
think light
is one of those key ingredients to that
graceful approach back to infinity
i love the honing in on the
map that is
as has been road mapped
out as well across these thousands of
years
and like you indicated earlier it's a
process of creating a sorting algorithm
we're
separating the wheat from the chaff or
we're draining the dirty bath water and
we're lifting up the
clean baby because there's a lot of
dogmas and fundamentalism and noise
and we also have to synthesize science
and spirituality in the process so
there's a lot to do here
and so we're creating this navigable
road map
that does that process for those that
are in
the very pole that we're sharing here
which is this
sort of matter and physical pull to be
able to navigate their way
towards the recognizing themselves as
the very source of awareness and
realities
and then to be able to like a jedi
navigate across this
back and forth with ease and with peace
and
grace like you say but the process to
get
from person consciousness to recognizing
recognizing
oneself as intelligent infinity that
process itself can be done with grace
and that process can be done with
basically taking the last
thousands of years of mystic wisdom and
making it so that
you don't go through this six-year atlas
process where atlas got hit with a bunch
of sledgehammers along the way
and we can we can make it more graceful
to where yeah we don't have to fall into
so many sledgehammers and crevices along
said way and so that's and we can make
it
fun and we can make it playful and we
can make it
around the eradication of malevolence
and suffering in the maximized human
potential we can provide
a big utility and a practicality
to this process of recognizing all that
you
look at is your own creation of one
intelligence at play with itself
and from there when you come
from the understanding
then you do it from a place of
joy and peace and maximizing potential
and not butterflying affecting out
malevolence and suffering because you
don't know
yourself that that's right that's right
yeah
exactly there's a there's a i think some
of the key ingredients are having a pure
intention
and having some good maps along the
lines of what we just talked about
and working with light and also
a conversation like this we're not just
sharing
ideas and concepts there is energy
vibration light being shared
in fact there's consciousness being
shared
so in fact this is a very significant
piece
of the puzzle where you can take
advantage
of this osmosis effect that happens
uh when you hang out with with people
who are very much deeply into this
and so there is a piece you get without
having to go through the usual
struggles all the pitfalls you get
you get a direct drink of the infinite
and that can save you a lot of trouble
and not to mention the delight and joy
aspect of it
is is much more evident
when you when you hang out with people
with high consciousness
and that's what has been taught for the
thousands of years as darshan it's the
direct
transmission of the radiant energy
of the sun and you can get
the taste of that by being around
those that have tasted it themselves
and that's in a sense the direct access
point
and so for example a top
recommendation for those that are very
much so still
in this very matter physical phase
would be people like eckhart tolle and
the power of now
sort of enables you to very slowly
migrate your way
in this direction and as you get closer
and closer to knowing yourself you can
jump to people like nisar gaza to
maharaja and i
am that and so that can be some of your
more just
doing more direct uh pointings
and then also you can take things like
the way suresh is putting this from a
place of transformation
is also a very beautiful and important
way of putting it because
the very nature of the beautiful lotus
flower
is that it grows out of mud and so
for you to recognize as carl jung and so
many of the others
greats have said is that your very roots
that reach down to hell are
exactly what enables your beautiful
fruits to reach
said heavens and so all of these
processes for you
of suffering there you're not the victim
to your own creation you're actually
leveraging that for as catalysts
for yourself to awaken and so the faster
you can
flip it from being a victim of life to
being the creator
of your own life and using these
catalysts for yourself to awaken
and to firework beautifully that's the
whole transformational
aspect when you go through the
navigation of transcendence and
integration and embodiment when you go
through the process of recognizing that
the very transformation
the very al chemistry happening at your
spark of the infinite is happening
be to you as the creator it's happening
for you you are the creator of it for
yourself
that that is a huge revelatory beautiful
unlocking process absolutely
absolutely because it's it's
tremendously
empowering to see that turns out
you know i'm i'm not climbing uh uphill
and somebody's trying to push me down
while i'm trying to climb up it turns
out
there's nobody trying to push you down
but turns out you you were having a
backpack full of heavy rocks that was
pulling you down
and once you see that all you have to do
is you know
open the backpack and toss the rocks out
and eventually you see that the rate at
which you can let go
of old stuff that will dictate
to a large extent how quickly you move
forward
and how beautifully it unfolds
if you fight the process by hanging on
to the rocks
then there's a lot of going back and
forth back and forth and you're like i'd
really like this why is it so hard
but you're not letting go of certain
things you can't let it go
gotta let all those rocks go and
some of these rocks i have to say they
don't
look like bad rocks see some of the
things were like
oh i had a horrible experience 10 years
back we can see this is a rock i want to
toss out
but then there are rocks which look
quite beautiful
they look like you know these are a
sense of self
like you know i'm so good at
so and so you know i'm a great swimmer
okay fine but that can turn out to be
a rock that you need to let go of it
just depends on how you relate to it
so if it's a sense of identity that's
limiting you it's become a rock that
looks good
now you have to eventually find a way to
let it go
there's no other way around it so
so there are there it can be confusing
because we we
are more culturally um
speaking about rocks that are painful
rocks
and not so much about rocks that look
good
we just feel like what's the problem
there you know
i'm a great athlete isn't that cool
everybody says cool yeah that's great
but when you start walking on this
particular path you start
looking at everything and saying
anything that binds me
to finite reality that's a problem
that's wrong it looks bad beautiful
color not so good color
doesn't matter it's binding you to
anything less than the infinite
so we got to let it go and so this is a
process this is where we
start getting smarter about letting it
go without a lot of
fuss i consider this as wisdom
you know wisdom is really very
simply and clearly seeing what the heck
is going on
and then without of us doing what needs
to be done
saying okay i can see this is no good
all right i'll let it go
done it could be as simple and as clean
as that
and i think this is the i think of as
where we are moving towards
we're currently where transformation was
a lot of us and we had a struggle we're
used to struggle struggle struggle
before
now we get on the path of transformation
and we're going to make sure it's a lot
of struggle
there it's like we're just using that
like i want to make sure you know this
is going to be
something that i own
you know yeah but it doesn't have to be
like that it can be very simple very
clean very elegant
very beautiful we can in a sense
very wisely and gracefully recognize
okay this is a big rock
and that i see it as a rock and i'm
going to lovingly
say thank you for the
suffering that you catalyzed in me
awakening
and now it's time to drop you and for me
to continue
onward in dropping the rocks that are
basically
binding us to finite reality the rocks
that are kind of like the layers to the
onion as well the very attachments and
stories
and forms of person identity and all
these things because once you
get to this top of the so-called flat
mountain
because you're already it but once you
sort of undergo these pops and become
more subtle and more formless recognize
yourself as the very source of awareness
and realities
then what happens is you can
express yourself from a place rather
than from the conditioning of the rocks
that are in your backpack
you're expressing yourself from a place
of pure love
light bliss peace service to others
beautiful and that's an excellent point
uh i want to emphasize one thing you
said in passing which is
when you are releasing these rocks you
you thank them because as
you were making your way through these
many finite incarnations
you are adapting you're actually very
smart you've adapted
so many times and some of those
adaptations
resulted in these rocks rocks are not
just like
just got there somehow these were
adaptations
which help you get to where you are so
there's
tremendous gratitude we have for these
rocks but we also have to say that the
adaptation of
yesterday is a male adaptation of today
okay because yes it helped me a lot but
now when i look at it
i don't need it it's time to let it go
so
it's a very dynamic process so we thank
it we let it go
we move on so this is the next level of
adaptation
towards our march back to essence
know perfect
ah this is
one of probably the most important
reflections on this navigable roadmap to
awakening through the veils veil
gateless gate these pops to recognizing
oneself a source of awareness and
realities
is that all of what
the contracted personhood identity is
for you right now that that
is the beautiful catalyst
for you to un contract to
relax that contraction to expand
yourself to these
more popped states of the infinite
and that is
like um if we can at least get that
step like into the very
matrixy dense physical reality
that your very suffering
is your very drill sergeant for
awakening so if you can at least
shift your lens from being a victim
to seeing your suffering as the actual
drill sergeant that's supposed to awaken
you
that that in itself can be such a
powerful shift
that then you start seeing it everywhere
like
oh that's actually you know bentino
massaro calls it the emotional guidance
system
right so you're you're getting this
emotional guidance
and spirituality is in a sense
realignment to that one heart
to infinite and that
to see that oh i'm feeling anger
and rather than spending minutes in the
cloud
of anger rather we become more and more
subtle and recognize the cloud of anger
was appearing and disappearing in the
sky of awareness
and then we recognize more and more that
that anger was actually guidance
for me to snap back to the peace and joy
of the awareness
and so we pick up the speed at which we
recognize those things
right right and another way of talking
about is
of that is the shift towards
a more beingness way of living
because what happens is ordinarily we
perceive reality in a certain way
and we look at it as here i am
and here's a book in front of me so
there's a subject object
uh way of looking at things as soon as
you look at it as subject and object
now it's there's a relationship going on
right
it's not just relationship with people
but with anything
you have a relationship and it becomes
now
about how do i have great relationships
in other words how do i have great
experiences because i want to have a
great life
and i want to have great experiences
it's all about
experiences with outside
objects and people this
orientation is taken us you know
in a certain direction you know humanity
because
we end up saying how can i do
the right things right because if i do
the right vacations have the right
relationships
acquire the right objects these are all
doings
if i do all the right stuff i'm going to
have great experiences
and life will be good
and so we chase experiences
through doingness
and this inherently set up for
failure no wonder everybody's failing at
that and suffering
but they keep thinking it's it's not
quite right maybe this other
investment is really what i need to try
or maybe this other kind of
person i need to meet then it'll be all
good
well it's not going to work out because
it's inherently set up for failure
to make you see that the subject object
thing
doesn't work it doesn't work because
it is based on a false premise there is
no subject there's no object
it's all one thing so you start moving
from an external orientation to an
internal orientation and in the internal
orientation
you sit with awareness and you start
seeing what's going on
and what you start seeing is this
underlying fabric
which is very unitive where
increasingly you cannot point at
anything and say that thing there is no
that thing there's all of that is
me so now
you end up with a different
way of living because the only thing
that makes sense then
is being there's nothing left to do
you can only be when you are full you
are
whole you are unified what are you gonna
do there's
nothing you could do in that orientation
you can only be
and that's why i summarize the 500 pages
of my book in the title
just be if you get that
you're okay and so the beingness way of
living so connecting it with what you
were saying earlier what does it look
like it looks like
a state of flow whatever is coming up
whether it's a emotion like anger you
were talking about
or some apparent
unfortunate circumstance all of these
things
are just perturbations within the field
of consciousness
all that is simply an undulation
your it doesn't throw you off so you can
stay in a state of flow
stay in being and as you do that i call
that
living as infinity because what you're
doing is
you're constantly in recognition of your
infinite nature
but you are functioning through this
finite point
in apparent time and space so you're
bringing that infinity to bear
upon this finite reality and that is
living as infinity it's not being either
or
it's either being caught up in infinity
or caught up in the finite reality
you are infinity and you are
functioning radiating expressing
in this so-called apparent
dimension apparent reality
perfect i'm so curious
how does the analogy
of the
how many different ways can you paint a
canvas
how many different ways can you arrange
musical notes into a song
how many different ways can you arrange
images into a movie
how many different ways can you put
together food into recipes
how many different ways can you vibrate
your vocal cords into languages
how does that style of an approach like
if you looked at planet earth
as one song
out of all of the possible songs aka
yuna
verse or if you looked at earth like
it's a beet salad
and like the next appearance of eternity
will be chicken soup
[Laughter]
yes yes in fact the more you step back
this is happening like all the time
there's eternity i mean
time and space are part of the paint
that's actually been thrown on the
canvas see we like to think of it as
this universe is this big chunk of space
there's a bunch of planets and stars
floating in it
and in that we're painting no
that whole thing is is a painting right
everything that including the space and
time
so because of that you know what's going
on
on our beautiful planet it's a speck
of the painting that's that's
up there on the canvas at this point in
so-called time
so it's it's really
i would say the takeaway is all as well
no matter
you know if it's your favorite salad or
not your favorite salad that's currently
being served
don't worry about it it's all good
it's all good
a way to potentially
tap into that analogy at a
deeper level would be do you know
yourself as the
source of all
endless combinations of food
into recipes because if you knew
yourself
as that then you could
playfully dance through whatever
recipe was currently being served
and and so this is the type of thing yes
are there going to be
aspects to let's say the chicken soup
that somebody is getting a portion of it
that might be
very very spicy
yes absolutely there are a lot of people
that are going through
very spicy lives and are there
also aspects of the chicken soup that
are kind of like just
right or is the entire thing in a sense
just inevitably perfect even through the
spicy sections
and the sections that are a little too
cold but that it's all
just that ineffable chicken soup or beet
salad or steak and potatoes or whatever
the creation
is it simply is that cameo
of eternity of the endless possibilities
of infinity expressing itself
but another aspect to this i would say
as much as the
firework of the infinite this would be
good to get your perspective here
you're very spark of infinity and
knowing yourself as that
is great as the source of the one
intelligence at play with itself
beautifully important yet also in a
sense
in the process of when you
go netti netti away from your person
consciousness
into awareness and away from awareness
even into the very impersonal
eternal awareness that all inclusive
great i am and then you pop
the observer is observed and so then
you pop into what is it that observes
the all-inclusive awareness
and the question then is what is that
very source
that creates that first attribute of
awareness and the
realities to immerse itself into as the
witness the observer
and so as you do that process what
happens is at that very last layer
you undergo a process of recognizing
that
even awareness itself the very
all-inclusive great i am awareness
that even that by being that first
attribute that it itself
is the most intoxicative assumptive
attribute we hallucinate the sense of
self
as this one intelligence we self-invent
the sense of i in order for there to
be a witness an observer
under awareness and so that process of
in a sense
going from an ottoman to an anatman
to going to anata to going to the very
state of that
no self the very void or emptiness
to at least be able to get to that as
well as one getting to recognize that
this is an endless fire working
the very a void void how do you feel
about that as well
yeah um so in fact it's it's
very much part of the model because
infinity
we haven't really defined infinity
because it's
it's a very tricky business because
infinity is the totality
and when you say the totality difference
infinity which is
pure consciousness which is
outside of everything we can think of
so in other words that's what i think of
as pure beingness
it's it's simply there and we
essentially find that
as we p level layers
we peel away all the relative aspects of
our being
until we bump into this core sense of
individuation
right and then that too
is released into the unknown because it
truly is the unknown we can
we cannot attach a single attribute of
any kind to this pure consciousness
but so we release ourselves into that
unknown
into the undefined and
at that point you really cannot say
a whole lot and and really it's it's
literally there's no there's no
particular
um creation that's relevant it's beyond
creation
it's beyond all of creation so
uh that's you could you could call that
as in a sense the combination
where you are drawn back absorbed into
the source
where you no longer can think of
yourself
as a separate emanation of any kind
it's one from beingness with pure
beingness that's that's
that's what i refer to as uh
it's understood that it's truly
ineffable indescribable not
characterizable
it we are so used to talking with
respect to creation
right almost everything all these
processes they
they tend to happen in creation but once
you cross that
line at that point
you you simply cannot say
anything so that the wisest amongst us
have simply said i'm not going to say
anything
that's it yeah that's close
to the reality yeah the the very tao
that can be named is not the eternal dao
yeah
yeah yeah just so simple just
recognize that language symbols
descriptions
will never be able to map the territory
itself
but we will get the coolest thing that
you can do
as you awaken is to try and make the
best maps
it's like that one yeah right
you know so we try to do our best
sitting here in this
fairly manifest reality but the cool
news is the most profound thing they can
ever think of that is already
right there part of you it's already
it's right there so so it's
it's even though we may you know bubble
back
through through all kinds of stuff but
the fact is
that's there even if we can't talk about
it
it's right there that's very powerful
and
very yet again very empowering
very empowering so no matter
what you can't miss it no matter what
happens
you're not gonna miss it because it's so
much built into you
so it's it's written on your forehead
right success yeah
you're you are gonna get there
because there's no way you're gonna miss
it it's built into you it's intrinsic
it's so fundamental
i loved this one as well this one was so
good
just said it
the coolest thing what is the coolest
thing that you can think of
and then somebody goes off and they're
like uh
i don't know you know it's like
this yeah just like
there's so much creativity
in our creation right here
right now so profound that
we designed this exploration
for the one intelligence to play with
itself through these veiless veils and
these gateless gates
in this dreamed ascensionary process of
awakening to
its true nature through all of our
insanity
of 100 million people dying
i bet that i can't
make a creation where i forget so
intensely that i kill 100 million people
in a hundred years
bad and there it is and so
to see it as that as the very creator of
it
is knowing yourself as was said
2500 years ago the delphic maxim the
number one
that was written on the top of the
temple of apollo adelphi
know thyself just know yourself as the
very source
as the very creator as the very
infinitude
exactly exactly and and that is
again as you feel into that
it can be as simple as that you know
everything you've heard
just feel into that kind of statement
i'm an infinite being
or i'm an infinite being of light just
feel into that
and you will find your consciousness
has shifted and so part of that process
is
we talked about letting go another piece
is the trust
in the unknown because even though we
can create hundreds of maps and
brilliant
things and everything at the end of the
day
you can't really say what it's all about
so it is this
it is very much a mystery it's very much
an unknown
and when you're right there at the edge
you you will feel that either i can stay
here
and be safe in the meanness
in spite of all its limitations i'm
going to feel safe as this little me
or i can cross this line into the
unknown
i don't know what that is not only that
i as me will dissolve
so i will become part of the unknown you
cannot step into the unknown and say
i'm going to still be the same for me it
doesn't work
you cross that line you step into the
unknown and after that point
you are yourself undefined
you're undefined and so there is some
trepidation
after all is said and done because
we have lived for a long time and we
love
knowing stuff characterizing stuff
staying in that space where everything
is known
everything is understood so we know what
exactly what we're doing
but i can tell you in spite of all the
stuff
the real thing is you're gonna step into
the unknown
so there comes an aspect where you're
just trusting in the infinite
not only infinite as out there but
infinity
as in here you're trusting in that
aspect of you
making a leap
and after that you dissolve into
infinity
you know never to be seen again uh in
in this in the way that you used to be
then all you can do is
appear like you're still there appear
uh like your radiant
representative of the infinite
this is such a profound
point as the dance the dance
that we do back to this very
undefinable as we merge
and you end up
uniting and you end up
dissolving the person identity
and rather what you end up being is you
end up being
a pure
firework in service to the infinite
to the one intelligence not in service
to an egoic layer of person conditioning
that's the difference
you don't you don't just completely oh
suresh has disappeared completely yeah
you stay
in this reality
but you become a pure steward
to the one intelligence rather than to
that
layer of conditioning yes exactly
exactly and there's no templates or any
such thing for that
it simply is whatever
it is uh it can look
very different so we don't want to be
too rigid about what that looks like
it'll look very different you just have
to trust it and honor
how it's happening for you
perfect yes
and it reminds me a lot
of the sufi metaphysic
which is
which is the unity of all finding
and so as suresh pointed out a moment
ago
is that every single one of these sparks
of the
infinite is going to have its own unique
taste and style of yoga of
union and so that's why as much as we
make this
road map of awakening that it's great
because it's the meta pattern of what
are the most sort of
common trajectories and how to avoid the
crevices and all this good type of stuff
yet at the same time just know that
you're going to have your own unique
taste and flavor of
union yes yes
and you know a characteristic that will
serve
you well is humility
humility is not about having a humble
mannerism or any such thing humility is
constantly recognizing a deeper truth
and yielding to that
and letting go of what you thought truth
was yesterday
because we have a tendency to calcify
around our understanding of truth
you're like i got it i did now i'm gonna
hang on to this
well tomorrow you have to let it go
because you you are face to face with a
more refined
truth this is humility
to let it go to let it go to let it go
constantly
constantly and so this yielding
is really what results in flow see
flow doesn't happen by you making it
happen right
flow is you're fully there
and you're constantly in touch and
yielding
constantly yielding yielding to infinity
tilting to infinity yielding to truth
pure being that is true humility
it's not about hanging on to some
concept
of what that looks like right we tend to
think
in terms of personas and things like
that this is nothing to do with a
persona
it's a quality of your being
yup
i love that definition that's really
good when humility is continuously
yielding to the truth
deepening and like you indicated
it becomes a quality of
being that's such a mission critical
that's when it's embodied
that's the last step it's when it's
embodied
it has become a quality of being
yes fantastic perfect
fantastic yes
ah there was a lot of great a lot of
great
ground covered there so
again the just be transform your life
and live as infinity the link is in the
bio below
and it's right there as well if you want
to see
this yes
there it is links in the bio below
and again as we said
swim in infinity the invitation to jump
in splash
in the light you can never be apart
from the infinite yoga mystism is simply
the union
with the absolute the three steps
transcendence
integration embodiment
and recognizing the
so-called pathless path
that we speak of
infinity in the fields of light the very
source light energy matter physical
you are the source of awareness and
realities
and the good old thank your rocks
suffering as catalyst for your awakening
humility continuously yielding to the
truth deepening
so many great profound wisdoms
with suresh on the show thank you
thank you it's it's as i suspected this
is
a total delight and
sure enough covered a lot of ground but
thanks to you great
great uh dialogue and questions and
commentary
and that i know doesn't just happen it's
due to your
inner work over many many
years so thank you for doing that for
sharing the way you've been sharing
and for giving in me an opportunity to
share some of my thoughts and likewise
right back at you with the inner work
that's been done in order
for you to be able to share actually
like you said before we started
that the seeking process typically also
comes with the sharing once one has
found
and so it's beautiful that you've
been able to share in such a
a way that gives a
map to the pathless path that can very
much deeply resonate with those that are
seeking to heal their confusion and
that's why
we brought you on and that's why there
was such a good tennis between us
because we're both so passionate about
exactly that
beautiful thank you again and thank you
to all the viewers for
hanging in there and splashing the light
with us
[Laughter]
yeah thanks everyone for tuning in we're
so grateful thank you
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode do let
us know
how you feel check out the links in the
bio below to suresh's website also to
the book link on amazon it's down there
and also if the video brought you value
give it a like it helps the algorithm
subscribe if you haven't yet to the
channel
and share the video with other people
that you feel like this would profoundly
resonate with we love you so much
thank you for tuning in and
let's wrap the episode i will
end the broadcast and we'll stay here in
the studio room
thank you everyone thanks
awesome